it's not about security it's just about
why would you let your girl have a
straight up marketing billboard of her
ass on the internet what the I
agree her so it's absolute and
if he had the right frame with her and
she was truly in love with him she would
happy to take that down that is
true and most men don't see that me and
pearl were talking earlier about a
relationship the guy said that
everything was good for the first seven
years and it's those little things right
there that that man didn't see because
he's like oh well she slept with another
dude well there was also the girls trip
there was also the post on Instagram
there was also the call from her High
School boyfriend that she got in the
middle of the night no bro she's been
telling you the whole time your frames
off then you got cheated on because she
doesn't respect you